the whole world witnessed what derek
chauvin did to george floyd
all right please be seated
members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict but it was a jury
that rendered the ultimate judgment
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
there was almost no reaction from the
former police officer
guilty on three counts of murder and
manslaughter
then like mr floyd handcuffed behind his
back
unlike mr floyd given the dignity of
being treated with respect
the trial examined in harrowing detail
the last moments of mr floyd's life
in may last year the justice that so
many had demanded
welcomed outside court the jubilation
mixed with
relief in a city and a country that had
been on edge
feeling better now nothing is going to
make it all better but at least
now there's some justices within minutes
the floyd family received a phone call
from the president
and vice president
who then addressed the nation to call
for this to be a moment america
embraces change we are all
a part of george floyd's legacy
and our job now is to honor
it and to honor him
i can't breathe i can't breathe
those are george floyd's last words
we can't let those words die with him
we have a chance to begin to change
trajectory
in this country it's my hope and prayer
that we live up to the legacy the images
of mr floyd's death are seared into the
consciousness of so many
perhaps most of all those of his family
i would salute him at every every day of
my life i would salute him
because he showed me how to be strong he
showed me how to be respectful
he showed me how to speak my mind
i'mma miss him but now i know he's in
history
yeah what a day to be a floyd man
so today is a pivotal moment
um for america
it's something this country's needed for
a long time now yes
and hopefully today is the start of that
when i say a pivotal moment
we need change in this broken system it
was built to oppress us
it was built against us
it isn't over yet chauvin's sentencing
and the trial of the other officers
there that day
lie ahead minneapolis and america were
waiting for this moment
but as the prosecutor said this was
accountability for one police officer
justice will take the work of a whole
nation greg milam sky news
minneapolis